I mean clearly Bitcoin has evolved a lot
it's in a short decade or so people had
the option of mining it in their
basements or in their garages that era
is over it's simply not economical to
mine Bitcoin in those environments it
has moved into industrial scale mining
where Bitcoin is mined in data centers
that are co-located uh close to energy
sources Bitcoin is moving into what what
I see and what we see is the third phase
of its Evolution we call it Bitcoin 3.0
where Bitcoin is becoming a constructive
partner to the energy ecosystem and
that's what we are focused on at R9 in
terms of building products for for this
third phase of Bitcoin and making sure
that we are delivering incredible value
for that
all right guys bang bang I've got Rajiv
here with me I thought a great place to
start this conversation would be to
unpack the geopolitical conflicts and
potential risks between the United
States China and other places around the
world help me understand aardine and
your personal perspective on the
importance of American manufacturing and
what the National Security implications
are of actually making stuff here in the
United States
um well first of all thanks a lot bomb
for having me on your show
uh geopolitics is uh become a fact of
life for uh all of us in the computer
industry and in life in general
um and what the there are several
factors that drive uh geopolitics uh
clearly there's uh you know countries
have their own national interests uh at
stake that they care about there's also
reasons that that were exposed and
became clear in the pandemic supply
chain shocks that the world saw
but from a United States point of view
there are a couple of things that are
very critical
in this era of geopolitical uh change
and and reality uh the United States
cares about its National Security and
that's a very very important aspect uh
because in a world uh where there are
Bad actors and bad uh National States
it's important the National Security
Becomes of elevated importance
in addition uh you know while the world
went through an era of globalization now
the world is moving towards an era of
what some people call deglobalization
and where you want to have greater
manufacturing within your Borders or
certainly within uh countries that that
are friendly and it becomes a a matter
of self-sufficiency and so the United
States has a chips act uh whose goal is
to drive that in the semiconductor area
and so that's a very very important
topic for the country and for all of us
as uh citizens of the United States
now when we start to think about uh some
of these risks uh what are the main
concerns are they
um people are worried that there's like
back doors in the hardware is it just a
pure self-reliance and so if a pandemic
or something like that happened again uh
there wouldn't be the ability for us to
manufacture stuff uh here in the United
States when you categorize these risks
like what are the big ones that you
think actually have validity and people
should be paying attention to
I think it's all of the above that you
said uh you know it's very important to
make sure that there aren't back doors
uh you know it's very important to make
sure that our national Secrets remain
Secrets
um so that's a very important aspect of
it but what has happened is that because
of the increased self-reliance of each
country on other countries there is the
opportunity for uh somebody to hold you
hostage and and really cause a big uh
impact to your economy right so it's no
longer nuclear warfare it's economic
warfare that's become uh very critical
and and so in order to protect against
that uh having
Manufacturing in the United States such
that we can supply what's essential for
our economy and that's our our financial
system our mobile and communication
system and the infrastructure to make EV
all of these applications that we are
become so used to and so uh that's
really why this has become extremely
important in the LA in the recent few
years
now when we start to look at uh kind of
solutions for this obviously one is uh
sanctions and kind of political or
diplomatic actions
um we have seen the United States begin
to ramp up some of those uh kind of um
you know weapons in our Arsenal if you
will to address this problem but also
companies whether they're in China or
elsewhere seem to be finding ways around
it Huawei being one that's been covered
pretty extensively in the in the media
talk a little bit as to like what is the
United States doing in terms of either
sanctions tariffs or other types of kind
of more diplomatic uh style uh weapons
to address this problem and then what
are companies in China or other
countries doing to try to evade those
sanctions and or other diplomatic needs
uh you know I think the United States in
my view doesn't is not fully aware of
everything that's going on uh I think
there's uh because of some of the more
recent news it seems like they are just
starting certain investigations to
really get to the bottom of what what's
going on and I think that I expect to
see that more of that to happen as as
things go forward now the specifics of
what's going on and how people await I'm
not privy to there are people who are a
lot smarter in trying to figure out how
to evade United States sanctions and so
forth and there are companies that do do
this all the time but I think the effort
and the initiative to prevent uh evasion
of these sanctions is just starting and
I think that that will uh as the United
States uncovers some of these things and
understands what's really going on uh
that they will take steps I'm fully
confident uh that that will happen it
may take a little time but I think we
are on that path uh to ensuring that
everybody complies with the laws and the
sanctions that are in place
now when we look at some of the
headlines uh for these specific
companies one is Huawei building a
secret Network for chips a trade group
warns another is mainland China's
development of a new 5G chip amid U.S
sanctions is expected to prompt another
round of Investigation by Washington
those are specific to chips and I think
when people hear chips they think
artificial intelligence and machine
learning and cloud computing and kind of
this rise of you know the AI world
how much of the concern is specifically
just around these chips versus its
Hardware in general and whether it is
you know Advanced Computing things like
artificial intelligence machine learning
or it could be something completely
different just maybe your smartphone
Hardware uh it's a concern across all
Hardware categories it is it is
definitely a concern across all Hardware
categories it's essentially a concern
about access to Leading Edge technology
because technology has this interesting
attribute which people call diffusion
right you can use Leading Edge
technology if you start using it in one
area it diffuses to other areas right so
you could start an artificial
intelligence and have it diffuse to
other areas or for example in our case
for example we are working on bitcoin
chips which require absolutely Leading
Edge process technology you could start
in a Bitcoin area and then it starts to
diffuse into artificial intelligence and
other areas so it's not one area versus
another it's really a competence see
it's really access to Leading us
Advanced Technologies that's what that's
what is very very critical
so let's talk about Bitcoin specifically
obviously there has been a lot of
improvement in Innovation around the
hardware if you go all the way back
people were mining Bitcoin on laptops uh
and eventually now we have Asics that
seem to be pretty Advanced where do you
all kind of evaluate how much better can
the hardware actually get and where do
you think the biggest areas of
opportunity are
yeah I mean clearly Bitcoin has evolved
a lot it's in a short decade or so uh
you know as you said it started in
laptops went into gpus uh and fpga type
Solutions and uh people had uh the
option of mining it in their basements
or in their garages uh that era is over
it's simply not economical to mine
Bitcoin in those environments so Bitcoin
has gone from being more of a hobbyist
and Speculator phase uh it has moved
into industrial scale mining where uh
Bitcoin is mined in data centers that
are co-located uh close to energy
sources
and where you know you can get access to
cheaper energy if you will
and uh and further I think Bitcoin is
moving into an era where it's not just
being
um mining of Bitcoin but Bitcoin is
moving into what what I see and what we
see is the third phase of its Evolution
we call it Bitcoin 3.0 where Bitcoin is
becoming a constructive partner to the
energy ecosystem and being providing
certain value uh in terms of uh using
wasted energy and balancing the Grid in
ways that people never imagined before
right now in order to do that clearly
Energy Efficiency is very critical and
you have to make sure that uh the power
consumption of Bitcoin mining is as low
as it can get and that requires very low
voltages uh it requires uh you know
making sure that uh its Leading Edge
process technology but it it requires
more than that right and that's what we
are focused on at R9 in terms of
building products for for this third
phase of Bitcoin and making sure that we
are delivering incredible value for that
let's talk about the specifics of what
you all have built you know the team is
comprised of people who are very smart
people with a lot of experience a number
of people on the team would be
considered you know kind of Legends of
Silicon Valley and some of the other
businesses that they were a part of and
helped to build companies that I think
the Modern Age of uh cohort of startups
look back and say wow if we can only
accomplish a fraction of what those
companies did we'd be in good shape and
so when you bring these smart
intelligent hard-working people together
you can really do anything right you
there are so much opportunity how did
you all decide okay what is the mission
of the business and what exactly are we
going to go start to build first
yeah when we started this company we saw
that we are in a period of unprecedented
Innovation and change uh in particular
blockchain and AI are technologies that
will exist with us for decades going
forward and will have a multiple
trillion impact on our lives on economy
and and as well on it
however if you look at those
Technologies the infrastructure
associated with those Technologies the
foundational infrastructure is simply
not at the level as the the prior
generations of Technology uh and so we
felt like we could make a serious dent
in this area and really unleash the
Innovation that can happen on top of
these Technologies going forward so
that's really what our big vision and
Mission was
I'm particularly proud of the team that
we have the team that we have has prior
experience at industry defining
companies like Palo Alto networks which
is a giant cyber security leader in the
world and then in companies like Nvidia
in cavium and Marvel and so forth and
between us what we have done is we've
really built foundational Technologies
infrastructure technologies that drive
secure uh Commerce secure Enterprise
that drive mobile and Cloud
infrastructure so things that we have
taken now for granted and have become
part of our lives but we think we can
make a massive Dent going forward in
that and so the team is extremely
capable of
um not just innovating but building
great companies and and working across
many transitions going forward
now let's talk about what this means
practically for a minor so a large scale
minor comes to you all and says show me
your products show me your services how
can you help me what is the difference
before they start working with Ardine to
what they actually can do after they
start working with you guys
yeah so today if you take a look at the
minor and any Miner first of all they're
buying all their products from
chinese-based companies that's number
one secondarily
the products have evolved from being a
hobbyist product to being deployed in
industrial scale mining so what they do
is they typically get the miner in some
cases they have to change the control
board the the firmware running on it
they have to apply a variety of
additional software Patchwork sometimes
they do it themselves sometimes they
work with ecosystem Partners so it's
really a patchwork to get uh two
operation and and going forward in
addition these products don't work
because the world has not a single
climate all the time you know things get
hot things get very cold and the miners
simply stop working and then in addition
energy providers sometimes want the
miners to curtail and they want them to
shut down these miners so they can shift
that energy to Consumers so it's a very
clergy system that exists in place today
okay and what we are bringing to Market
is a revolutionary uh product that's
built from the ground up it's built for
data center scale as opposed to
hobbyists operation we have a leading
Energy Efficiency
we have a first product we have a
amazing road map in front of it that
that's coming behind it so we have
leading performance and Energy
Efficiency which I believe is stable
Stakes at this point in time but beyond
that what we have done is we've added
some unique innovations
that fall in a few areas first is
something that we call Energy tune and
that technology allows for these miners
to go up and down in terahash rates or
in power consumption in a very Dynamic
fashion without reboots and be able to
achieve that within a matter of seconds
because utilities need that level of
responsiveness for appropriate demand
response very beneficial for Miners and
very beneficial for utilities
second thing is you know as you deploy
these miners in harsh conditions in the
middle of a desert where energy is
stranded for example renewable energy is
stranded or next to a natural gas
flaring site you want these miners to
keep operating in a wider operating
temperature range
um you know very low temperatures very
high temperatures and we build a system
with very high quality to keep operating
delivering higher up times okay so
that's another important attribute and
then finally all of this boils down to a
much better total cost of ownership from
a minor point of view right so they
don't have to do a lot of uh capex uh
upfront uh r d up front to get these
products deployed they are out of the
box they can be deployed very easily
they are up more of the time so they get
a better benefit they get better
economics from curtailment so all in all
it's just a much much better uh total
cost of ownership for the miners
now when you start to look at these
individual minors one of the parts that
becomes fascinating to me is this
ability to have a very specific control
right you can actually turn things on
you can turn them off you don't have to
do entire sites talk a little bit about
the interface with these electrical
grits we've now seen a number of stories
that came out in August as an example
where uh Riot and other large miners
were actually quote paid money from the
electrical grids uh for turning off
their power now that's not a secret deal
it's not some special deal that they got
with ercot but but it's something that's
available to anyone in kind of these
industrial facilities but how do you
think this evolves over time you know
we're entering a weird world where if
you are going to use A6 you can mine
Bitcoin or you can shut them off right
you can get paid from the electrical
grid if you look at other things like
you know ethereum mining uh in the past
you're able to use gpus which obviously
many people were using specifically for
ethereum mining but we've now seen
companies like core we've come out and
say actually we're going to Pivot we're
gonna go after artificial intelligence
or machine learning type applications
you then see ethereum move from a proof
of work to a proof of stake system all
of that Hardware becomes you know
obsolete in in regards to ethereum and
so it has to be redirected somewhere
else is it something where you just stay
focused on Bitcoin mining and Asics are
going to be A6 and that's kind of the
the full Focus or do you all see some of
the lessons that you're learning some of
the technology and Innovation that
you're driving you can actually go and
apply to other areas than just Bitcoin
mining specifically yeah so well first
of all Bitcoin mining is a product line
that we are executing on uh as I
mentioned we have uh initial products we
actually have uh probably the most
comprehensive set of products in this
area that range from Air cool to single
phase to dual phase emotion a bunch of
unique uh form factors that people care
about and we'll continue to innovate and
build roadmap uh on on that but what
we're finding as you pointed out uh you
know accurately is that companies are
looking at adding Ai and uh you know
certain Bitcoin miners have very strong
interest in becoming AI data centers and
AI is has applicability not just outside
the few large Cloud companies but also
in the edge and in data centers that are
outsided so
from our point of view we are seeing
customers asking us to uh Flex our
muscle in our infrastructure talents in
those areas in unique ways right and as
I mentioned earlier our team has
outstanding talent in being able to
deliver
um sustainability a security and
scalability for uh blockchain and also
now for AI and so
um peer generative AI has come and
exploded on the scene uh everybody is
now familiar with chat GPT everybody's
familiar with llm large language models
and there are certain initial use cases
but we all know that over the next two
three five years those use cases will
explode
having said that there are two big
issues that exist one is this whole
notion of Ip leakage this notion of
copyright infringement you get a
response from one of these llms can you
use it or are you infringing on
someone's IP or are you leaking your own
intellectual property to a model that's
going to take it and train it
um and uh there are additional issues
regulatory issues compliance issues
cyber security issues
and so any new technology has positives
has holes and gaps and has negatives and
so we believe we can
um bring to bear uh certain unique
security capabilities in this new area
and we are working on just amazing
products here that we will bring to
Market so not only will we enable the
next generation of AI data centers and
next generation of AI applications but
make sure that they can happen in a very
secure fashion that people's privacies
can be protected that bad actors cannot
attack them and bring down and then over
time I think AI right now is too
expensive it is extremely power
consuming and and it's and it's really
not at that level for extremely wide
adoption and we will play a role in
making that uh happen as well
when you look at what's going to be
needed to be able to do that how much of
this is hardware Innovation versus uh
maybe it's just a capital game if you
can get enough Capital then you can go
and do it uh maybe there's a courage
element to it right it's just somebody's
got to stand up and say hey doing this
in the United States in a certain way is
very important we're willing to go you
know kind of be the flag bearer to do it
what's needed to go from where we are
today to kind of this world that you
guys Envision uh moving forward it's
just uh it's just bright folks uh
working with customers understanding
applications and pain points but more
importantly people who have uh the the
stomach and the ability to attract the
capital and go long okay that's very
important aspect to it and
um you know we have shown time and again
across uh years that the United States
really delivers the world's best
technology and I think we will continue
to do that
and so in terms of Hardware versus
software It's a combination
um you know we all know that Moore's Law
is at its limit
um you know the world is moving from
general purpose Computing to accelerated
Computing
um in part to address the Slowdown of
Moore's law and the rate of compute
growth so it will be a combination of
accelerated Hardware coupled with
Innovative software and a grounds up
security design because some of the
Legacy architectures
that really made sense uh in a pre uh
generative AI era simply don't work in a
world when uh the two endpoints that are
talking to each other are not talking uh
through networking uh language uh or
computer language but they're talking
through human language and in a world
where devices are talk to each other
using human language uh the challenge of
understanding that human language and
enforcing Security on that is much more
complex and much more different
and so it opens up incredible
opportunities to build this uh
groundbreaking products and deliver
incredible value uh for this upcoming
wave
one of the aspects that we talked about
earlier was the US government using
political and diplomatic means in order
to prevent uh certain Hardware from
entering the United States what about in
Reverse as you all manufacture many of
these whether they're chips Bitcoin
mining equipment or other types of
Hardware will there be limitations on
your ability to sell it to people
internationally or to get into the hands
of uh individuals or companies that are
in various other jurisdictions you know
there very well might be I mean this
whole notion of uh you know doing the
right thing for the country is very
important as as I mentioned earlier we
are working on leading as advanced
technology in the semiconductor space as
well as in the security space as well as
in the artificial intelligence area
and so from our point of view we are
while we obviously want our technology
to be adopted as as widely and as
globally as possible we are also very
mindful of the fact that we live in a
different world and geopolitical factors
and National Security factors have
become more important than ever before
and so certainly we are going to comply
with and really partner with the US
government to make sure that the right
policies are put in place
and then when you start to look at the
Bitcoin mining uh kind of uh industry we
have seen a number of the large miners
they are playing this game of hey we're
going to do mining whether that is
Bitcoin or other assets and we also are
going to plan the advanced Computing
space what it makes me think is you all
are doing something similar in a
different way right you guys are
obviously going to go much more after
kind of chips and Hardware manufacturing
and distribution is this going to be the
natural state of companies is this kind
of like the end game where all of these
businesses that are in the computational
kind of industry are going to end up
having to have one foot in Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency world but also another
foot in artificial intelligence machine
learning cloud computing and other kind
of advanced uh computational sectors
uh you know I think they are not two
completely different worlds I think
they're they're worlds that uh will
converge in the future uh and I think
that it makes a lot of sense right in a
world in a in a AI world where there are
AI assistants who are doing transactions
on your behalf uh they are buying
airline tickets or making restaurant
bookings and giving your credit card
information out
um you know blockchain has an a critical
role to play as part of that because
these transactions will be done uh in
using internet rails as opposed to your
credit card rails
um you know money transfer and so forth
will happen so that's one place where Ai
and blockchain will converge another
place where Ai and blockchain and
certain related Technologies like zero
knowledge proofs converges uh is the
fact that when you're talking to
somebody for example right now how do I
know it's the it's the real pomp or is
it really a deep fake that that I'm
talking to
um you know I want to be able to be sure
of that and Technologies blockchain
technologies will allow me to feel the
confidence that I'm talking to a real
person rather than a deep fake uh that
was created using generative AI so so
there are opportunities of convergence
there are also if you look at the flip
side of it when you when you're
executing smart contracts on blockchain
AI will provide the data and the guard
rails and capabilities for those smart
contracts to execute so there is a
convergence in in our future that that
is definitely coming
and so what you see here is not an
opportunistic play but a long-term uh
thinking of how these things converge
and how we take advantage of it on the
technology side uh as we build these
products there is a lot of complex math
that is the underpinning of both of
these Technologies right and so some of
the Silicon capabilities and low power
capabilities that we have applied to
both areas
and so there is a natural uh convergence
going forward and I think what you what
you're seeing is the beginnings of that
now you all have products out in Market
you're already been executing on this
you raised quite a bit of capital for an
early stage company to go and do this
successfully what has been the response
so far from customers what what are they
saying in terms of the things that uh
you all are doing well and serving their
needs and then what are the areas where
they're saying hey if you guys could do
a b or c uh that'd be really valuable
for us
yeah I mean we've spoken to a number of
customers every time we go and tell them
about what we are doing uh they're
telling us that we hit all of their pain
points right you know this whole notion
of uh energy tuning that people refer to
as overclocking and underclocking uh you
know in this uh in in a previous era so
they just love it this notion of you
know making sure that everything works
well with each other
um they just simply love it uh the
response has been extremely positive
um and so we have a number of customer
engagements on in process we actually
have orders of our products in in
process and people are encouraging us to
keep executing on this and then people
also are very interested in what we are
going to bring to Market in the AI space
so I think there's a great relationships
that are forming at this stage and we
are delighted to partner with a number
of leading uh mining customers as well
as Enterprise customers
now there's a whole wide range of people
who listen to this podcast and so I
thought maybe we could kind of do a
little bit of round robin and you could
deliver a message to each one of them uh
maybe first what we could start with is
U.S politicians and kind of people who
are in that apparatus where uh they may
or may not be aware of some of the
problems uh or the risks that we face
and and they likely have the ability to
do something or at least suggest to
their colleagues to do something what do
you think is kind of the best message
for us to deliver to them I think for
U.S politicians I think one thing has
become clear everybody has become aware
and in alignment uh for the geopolitical
issues that exist in our world across
both parties so that's extremely
positive historically that's not always
been the case uh but I think the time is
now to move to action uh Beyond uh uh
talking and I think the time is now to
really investigate and make sure that
the right things are happening uh with
regard to regulation and making sure
that all the laws and that they have put
in place are really being complied to so
I think that's the most important
message I would convey to the
politicians
but people are founders and
technologists these are people who
probably are sympathetic to uh kind of
this uphill battle that you all are
taking on and are cheering for you but
what would be the message to those
technologists whether they're potential
people who could come and work with you
all uh people who could partner with you
or people who are just building other
technology companies uh that that happen
to just be in a very broad similar field
yeah especially in deep Tech which is
the area that uh we focus on uh building
companies is not straightforward but I
think that the
um the thing that works is number one is
uh you know track record helps
tremendously uh um the ability to
attract Capital helps tremendously but
then beyond that Innovation and
persistence is absolutely key and what
we've seen time and again uh is that
people get into a market try to do
something for one or two years and then
they find it's too hard and then run
away from the market and if you look at
the uh the reason one of the biggest
reasons for the success of the team we
have is the fact that not only are these
extremely talented people but they have
the ability to go long and ability to go
through ups and downs and I think that
is very critical for any entrepreneur or
founder that wants to build a company in
the deep deep Tech space
another group is obviously customers and
potential customers these are people who
look at teraflux and they say hey that
could be interesting for me what is your
message to them
you know reach out to us
um we're as I mentioned we had we had
engaged with a number of customers you
know you can come to our website we'd
love to talk to you and explain to you
in great detail not just what we have
today but what's coming in the pipeline
behind this and uh and then the second
thing I want to tell these customers is
we are here to stay so don't worry about
uh you know folks that came in and
jumped out of the market Our intention
is to stay and build an infrastructure
company uh that is going to be around
for a very long time an iconic company
we think in the in the Silicon Valley in
the United States and uh we'd love to
partner uh and and so
um you know that's that's what I would
tell these folks
got it and lastly maybe is like what's
the message to yourself every morning
when you get up and you go to work and
you're excited to do it you know I spent
some time talking with myself and the
team and obviously you guys were really
really
um I think ambitious but also uh
rational in terms of the work that needs
to be done and that this is not going to
be easy but what do you tell yourself
every day when you get up to go to work
and and kind of stay motivated to keep
going after this hard problem
uh you know the there's a lot of people
uh as as everybody says entrepreneurship
is hard and so forth
um I've done done it a few times you
know I'm not doing this to uh pay the
mortgage or or save money for retirement
uh I'm doing it because this is an
opportunity to make a massive impact uh
it's it's an opportunity to learn and
it's an opportunity to have fun
um the team that we have the culture is
is extremely fun it's extremely
collaborative culture
um and uh the other important thing is
we are going long and so the only way
you can get go long is when you're
having fun if you're if you're stressed
out and working hard and you're killing
yourself you'll burn out that's not a
recipe for long-term success
um so every morning when I get up I'm
excited about what's happening around me
in the world I you know I I see your
tweets I read a lot about both
blockchain and Ai
and uh and then you know I come in and
we we have great fun solving some
amazing problems
that's awesome where can we send people
to find uh more about the company online
or more about the products you guys
already have that people can come in
order uh well the best place is to go to
our website auradine.com that's
a-u-r-a-d-i-n-e.com
um and I encourage people to reach out
to us we'd love to hear from you
awesome Rashid thank you so much for
taking the time to do this I learned a
ton and you know as I said in the intro
uh one of the things that uh is
compelling to me is people in the United
States who recognize the geopolitical
risks that we face and say rather than
sit and complain about it or rather than
yell and scream at our politicians
there's also something that private
citizens can do and then you know this
idea of competing rather than
complaining to take on uh you know this
problem and say look if we can go and we
can build something that is as good
quality if not better if we can innovate
and really iterate iterate our way to
solutions to these problems and do it
here in the United States with American
manufacturing
um it is something that hopefully will
inspire other Founders or private
citizens to say look complaining isn't
necessarily the the solution instead I
can actually go build something I can
act and so hopefully more and more
people will follow the steps that you
and your team have taken
well thank you very much uh pomp it's
been a pleasure and thank you for
inviting me to the show and uh look
forward to seeing you in person soon